One of the most famous trends is probably one
you have heard of, it's Moore's Law. Moore's Law
roughly states that every one and a half to
two years, we will fit twice the number of
transistors on the same chip area. So this is
what technology improvement promises to do. As computer architects,
we try to translate that into doubling the processor
speed every 18 to 24 months. So what we
try to do is, if the technology can give us
twice as many transistors, we try to translate that into
doubling the processor speed. We also try to reduce the
energy per operation to about half it was every 18
to 24 months. Pretty much. The transistors are now half
the sizes they used to be, so we try to
translate that into using half as much energy for the
operation of the same work. And we try to double
the memory capacity every 18 to 24 months.
So we can fit twice as many transistors
on the same chip area. We tried to
translate that into having twice as much memory, if
this is a memory chip. Again note that,
this is what the technology can be expected
to do and this is what architects are
expected to do with that technology. That way we
can plan for what the technology will be able to provide us with, and we
know what the computer market will expect from our future computers.